We are all special people, but the most important question is: Are you normal?
For example, if you are right, you are normal.
85% of the world's population as well.
Even if both parents are easier, your chance to be like them is only 25%.
But if you can not roll your tongue, you are not normal.
65% to 81% of people can do it.
Your hair is dark? this is normal. Only 0.5% of humans have red hair.
Have you uprooted the wicked of reason?
Around 65% of people around the world need to do so.
If you wear glasses, it may be a growing natural pattern
Which affects about 2.5 billion people around the world.
Children's activity is believed to be growing within the home
Exposing them to myopia.
If you are single in the United States you are also normal.
50.2% of adults in America are single,
Which is a major shift since 1970 when only 37.4% were unmarried.
However, 80% of adults around the world are married.
Regardless of social status,
The average age of possession was born in the United States
Is 22.8 years for women and 25.4 for men.
While the average in a country like Chad is 17.9, while Greece is 31.2 years old.
If you have a girl named Sophia or her derivatives,
You are like most natural parents.
He is the most prominent name born in 9 countries.
If you have safe protected sex, you are also normal.
65.8% of men between the ages of 15 and 44 stated using condoms in the first sex practice.
While in 2006 it was only 47.7%.
This trend is more common among adolescents between the ages of 15 and 19,
78.1% of them used the condom for the first time.
But what is the natural age to lose your virginity?
Sexual intercourse is defined as intercourse with the vagina.
The Centers for Disease Control found that the average age of American women when they lose their virginity is 17.2 years,
The men are 16.8.
do you have a job? 61.3% of people work in the most common or regular jobs in America,
Such as retail business, followed by accounting and office functions
Preparing and providing food, nursing and working as a waiter.
But if you provide food to someone who enjoys the milk as in his childhood, it is not normal.
About 75% of adults in the world have a form of lactose intolerance.
Which means that they have experienced irritating digestive symptoms of dairy products.
If they are vegetarians they also understand the minority, with only 4-5% in North America,
Just over 30% in India excise meat from their diet.
Is your birthday in February? You have a strange!
Most people are born between August and September.
Statisticians explained that the lower temperatures people spend less time abroad,
What is called to stir things up in the bedroom.
Nine months later, many children are born.
These babies are fed by a medium size bra in America 36c,
Which increased from 34B to 15 years ago.
The average size of penis erections? 13 cm or 5 inches.
Which is smaller than that found in preliminary studies,
However, most of these studies were based on self-report versus actual study measurements.
If you do not feel completely normal now do not worry,
We have a full section on why humans are also strangers.
Such as why water seeps out of our eyes when we mourn,
Or why do we split to show approval?
Click the screen or link in the description of this video.
Subscribe to get more weekly science videos every Thursday.
Translation: team translate @autrjim